ein neuer bericht des weltklimarates
schlägt jetzt alarm demnach muss jetzt
sofort dringend und umfassend geändert
werden ansonsten wäre eine weitreichende
zerstörung unseres planeten kaum noch
aufzuhalten
die welt ist im moment weder in der lage
ein klimaziel von 15 noch von zwei grad
zu erreichen der temperaturanstieg
dürfte deutlich stärker sein klick zum
science fiction
hier gibt's täglich science videos
abonniert den kanal dann verpasst ihr
nichts herzlich willkommen das ist mal
eine ansage der weltklimarat hat sich
mit dem klima ziel von 1,5 grad befasst
dies geschah auf bitten der
entwicklungsländer die besonders stark
von den konsequenzen des zwei-grad-ziels
betroffen wären deren ländern nämlich
werden im wahrsten sinne des wortes von
der landkarte verschwinden bzw würden
durch den anstieg des meeresspiegels
stark schrumpfen
das ergebnis in den nächsten zehn jahren
muss endlich nachhaltig gehandelt werden
zitat diese dinge müssen sofort
einsetzen die nächsten zehn jahre sind
entscheidend in ihren auswirkungen das
sagt hans otto pörtner im gespräch mit
dem spiegel der meereswissenschaftler
ist ko vorsitzender der arbeitsgruppe 2
des weltklimarates und damit für den
aktuellen bericht entscheidend
mitverantwortlich mit diesen dingen
meint er energieerzeugung landnutzung
städtebau verkehr und bau sowie
industrie für diesen neuen bericht haben
91 autoren und autorinnen 6000 studien
ausgewertet
doch diese anderthalb grad marke ist
kaum noch zu erreichen da wir bereits
einen anstieg von mindestens 1 bis 1,2
grad haben die ergebnisse der studie
das klimaziel eines geringeren
temperaturanstiegs würde mit mittlerer
sicherheit zehn millionen menschen
weniger vom anstieg des meeresspiegels
betreffen
der würde nämlich 10 cm weniger
ansteigen würden mit hoher sicherheit
signifikant weniger arten aussterben mit
mittlerer sicherheit würden etwa 1,5 bis
2,5 millionen quadratkilometer
permafrostböden nicht auftauen hier
würde dort gespeicherte kohlenstoff
nicht in die atmosphäre entweichen und
den klimawandel weiter beschleunigen die
arktis würde mit sicherheit nur
einmal im jahrhundert komplett eisfrei
stadt jedes jahrzehnt in diesem zustand
beschert uns das offene meer extreme
niederschläge und eben extrem wetter
würde es mit mittlerer sicherheit
deswegen und wegen anderer reduzierter
ursachen deutlich weniger gibt zitat das
vorsorgeprinzip ruf drastisch dazu auf
in aktion zu treten so pörtner im
spiegel in deutschland die gesteckten
klimaziele aufzugeben oder weiter lustig
braunkohle abzubauen ohne rücksicht auf
verluste
das geht gar nicht so kann man partner
problemlos interpretieren und es ist ja
seit der fraunhofer studie bekannt dass
die klimaziele in deutschland erreichbar
wären wenn denn nur die politik wollte
es muss dringend effektiver gegen co2
vorgegangen werden so partner in
deutschland sind alleine drei millionen
menschen vom steigenden meeresspiegel
betroffen so steht es in einem bisher
unveröffentlichten bundestags papier das
dem spiegel vorliegt und der extrem
heiße sommer wie in diesem jahr der hat
vermutlich zehntausende tote gefordert
extremwetter wie sie immer öfter in den
usa aber auch eben hier in europa
auftreten werden immer mehr nur wenn wir
das steuer wirklich herumreißen haben
wir noch eine chance und dazu sagt der
neue bericht ganz klipp und klar was
nötig ist bis 2050 müssen 70 bis 85
prozent des weltweiten stromverbrauchs
durch erneuerbare energien erzeugt
werden
kohle darf ab 2050 nicht mehr genutzt
werden feuer muss der verbrauch
drastisch reduziert werden die industrie
muss den co2 ausstoß um 75 bis 90
prozent senken co2 muss im großen stil
aus der atmosphäre entfernt werden im
großen und ganzen ist die ansage klar in
den nächsten 30 jahren müssen die co2
emissionen bis 2050 eben auf null
gesenkt werden co2 das dann noch in die
luft gelangt zum beispiel durch den
flugverkehr muss wieder aktiv aus der
luft entfernt werden laut pörtner gibt
es so seine privatmeinung keinen grund
wie arbeitsplätze und weitere vorwände
das erreichen der ins auge gefassten die
maschine zu verzögern denn im zweifel
sei ergänzte ich mal gibt es mehr tote
durch den klimawandel und zwar auch hier
in europa als arbeitsplätze bewahrt
werden aber im moment sieht es nicht
danach aus wenn ich mal die realität
sondern nur die zusagen der industrie
nationen im rahmen des pariser
klimaabkommens
nehmen so der bericht des weltklimarates
steigt die temperatur um insgesamt 2,6
bis 4 grad
weltweit wird das aber und abermillionen
menschen betreffen
und dann wird es auch hier in europa
extrem ungemütlich ich werde auf jeden
fall dran wenn ihr als erstes neues zum
klimawandel und zu allen anderen themen
erfahren wollt dann endet meine
telefonnummer hierbei whatsapp dann
erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen
vom neuesten video täglich garantiert
und zur begrüßung gibt es noch ein
kleines geschenk einfach hier
draufklicken und natürlich nicht das
aber mit der glocke vergessen und
darunter geht es weiter auch dafür drauf
klicken so kann deutschland seine
klimaziele doch noch erreichen da geht
es um die von greenpeace in auftrag
gegebene studie des fraunhofer
institutes ansonsten würde ich mal sagen
bis dann bleibt bleibt